In 2014 I announced one of my boldest
companies.
It's a company called Human Longevity
Inc.
Uh,
Co founded it with Craig Venter,
the first guy sequenced the human
genome.
Uh,
and Bob Hariri,
one of the top stem cell scientists and
businessmen in the world.
And we founded human longevity
incorporated as a means to extend the
healthy human lifespan to make a hundred
years old.
And you're 60.
And in the first year of operations,
we built the largest genome sequencing
facility in the world.
Uh,
and that genome sequencing facility
besides your genome,
uh,
the 3.2 billion letters from your father
and the 3.2 billion letters from your
mother,
we are also sequencing your microbiome.
You are a collection of 10 trillion
human cells and a hundred trillion
bacterial cells.
But besides that,
you're full phenotype,
your,
uh,
your Mri,
the full imaging of your body,
your Metabolome,
the 2,400 chemicals in your bloodstream.
All of this data is being collected.
And then we're using machine learning to
mine that data for the secrets of what
drives cancer,
what drives heart disease,
what drives neurodegenerative disease.
With a mission of making sure that when
you're a hundred,
you look good,
you move good,
you think good,
you feel great.
And uh,
I think that's where we're going.
Our ability to rapidly sequence a
genome,
take what was $100 million and nine
months down to 1000 bucks in a few
hours,
is going to unlock the secrets.
We are the product of our genome.
How you look,
how you sound,
the structures of your brain are all
coded for in our genes.
So as we unlock this,
we're going to create tremendous
breakthroughs in the healthy human
lifespan.
Inventing new drugs that are
personalized to you.
It's going to reinvent health on an epic
scale.